vier hufe und zwei füße das hier sind
nicht nur reisegefährten sondern zwei
echte freunde
[Musik]
in der nähe von starnberg südlich von
münchen unternimmt die schauspielerin
einen kleinen ausflug mit ihrem johnny
er ist ein esel zum pferdestehlen seit
vier jahren sind die beiden ein
eingespieltes team
[Musik]
und beide verbindet das besondere am
zaun ist dass er mich aus meinem
stressigen alltag raus bringt und dass
er der beste kumpel überhaupt ist der
beste reisepartner und der beste zuhörer
kein wunder bei den ohren schon als kind
hat lottelo call den ungewöhnlichen
wunsch mit einem esel auf wanderschaft
zu gehen
doch sie erfüllt sich ihren großen traum
erst nach einem schicksalsschlag
ganz plötzlich mein papa schwer krank
geworden 2015 er die diagnose magenkrebs
bekommen
das ist unheilbar ist und dass wir halt
nicht mehr viel zeit miteinander haben
und dann habe ich mich noch um ihn
gekümmert bis er gestorben ist und
werden ganz viel intensiv zeit
miteinander verbracht und dann habe ich
mich daran erinnert dass ich ja auch so
einen traum hat schon ganz lange den ich
gerne machen möchte mir einen esel zu
kaufen und mit dem wandern zu gehen und
dann dachte ich mir okay ich habe keine
ahnung was morgen passiert jetzt oder
nie über eine kleinanzeige findet lothar
lockl ihren esel
es ist schnell klar die beiden gehören
zusammen nach monaten der vorbereitungen
geht es im sommer 2008 zehn los lothar
lutzke wandert mit johnny von münchen
über die alpen bis an die italienische
adria küste rund 600 kilometer in 80
tagen
manchmal wäre ich auch wesentlich
schneller unterwegs gewesen wenn sie
schon nicht dabei gewesen wäre zb wenn
er gerade angst hat vor einer brücke
horizon das wasser unten drunter ist und
die kinder hat dann hat er natürlich
angst dass oder einbrechen dann kann das
schon mal 20 minuten dauern bis er sich
dann über eine brücke traut ja dadurch
kommt man ja doch recht lange davor
werden
also wenn man stress hat und schnell
irgendwie wohin wandern möchte dann
würde ich keinem empfehlen
durch ihren tierischen gefährten lernt
sie vor allem eins gelassener zu werden
über ihre erlebnisse mit einem esel zu
wandern hat die 28 jährige ein buch
geschrieben und das duo bleibt eine
reise gemeinschaft nun sind sie sogar
motorisiert unterwegs
der umgebaute kleinbus ist nicht nur
wohnmobil sondern auch eine tiergerechte
transportbox so kann esel johnny sicher
mitfahren
hier war es halt wichtig dass er nicht
hinten im hänger drin steht wo ich
keinen direkten bezug zu ihm habe
sondern wirklich so direkt hinter mir
wenn ich fahre ist nur das gitter
dazwischen ich kann mich mit ihm
unterhalten und man sich auch nichts
entgeht wir steht aber drin
ja genau und so macht das coupé und zwar
so gut dass sie sich im dezember 2020 in
ein neues tierisches abenteuer stürzen
mit dem bus bis nach portugal aus
rücksicht auf esel john hurt locker look
cool dabei nie mehr als eine stunde pro
tag drei monate lang sind sie unterwegs
pauli wo willst du dann als nächstes hin
ich glaube als nächstes also wir sind ja
gerade erst von einer großen reise
zurückgekommen
ich glaube dieses jahr gehen wir
wirklich einfach mal in den alpen
wandern und zu für uns dann ein paar
schöne plätze aus wovon hier halte
stunde hin fahren und dann einfach mal
ein paar tage wandern können
[Musik]